[Musique]
comment
ne vous fiez pas à la déco sous les
parasols
on bosse les docks numériques sont un
espace de coworking entendait un espace
de travail partagé des personnes ont
beau le vrai côte à côte
elles n'appartiennent pas toutes à la
même entreprise leur employeur leur loue
un bureau pour 319 euros par mois pas de
bail contraignant des frais allégés
on comprend bien l'intérêt pour les
entreprises mais pour les comores coeur
avec ses ordinateurs pierre-marie
m'inscris aurait pu dépanner le réseau
de radios musicales pour lequel il
travaille depuis sa cuisine par exemple
mais il n'en avait pas envie on a quand
même besoin de faire du lien et garder
un lien avec d'autres personnes on n'est
pas enfermé chez soi dans le coin
sylvère denis a cofondé cet espace il ya
huit ans avec ses associés il était
parmi les pionniers en france
à l'époque le concept de co working ne
parlait pas à grand monde sauf à ces
jeunes entrepreneurs qui travaillaient
tous dans le monde de l'informatique de
la net économie et des startups le lieu
à conserver cette coloration numérique
pour favoriser les échanges et la mise
en réseau entre l'éco voir qu on a eu
des collaborations qui sont faites entre
plusieurs utilisateurs certains qui
étaient développeurs d'autres qui
travaille dans le marketing qui avait
besoin sur des projets justement de
mutualiser des compétences donc on
plutôt que d'aller chercher de l'autre
côté de la france où ils ont pu
travailler ensemble et puis on a vu même
des projets d'entreprises se créer
[Musique]
changement de décor chez qatar le non
sucré du lieu pourrait laisser penser
qu'on pousse la porte d'un salon de thé
et pourtant nous sommes dans un autre
espace de travail partagé un café comme
work
s'il n'y a pas de bureau possible on
trouve un arrangement une armoire qu'il
soit dans l'espace là ou là bas florence
shih a ouvert ce lieu il ya un peu moins
d'un an pour tous les travailleurs
nomades qui n'ont pas besoin d'un bureau
dédié en permanence comment en est-elle
eu l'idée grâce à son vécu en se
rappelant son passé de commercial qui
écume et les bistrots
entre deux rendez vous je me suis rendu
compte qu'ils avaient soit pas de wifi
soit pas de prise électrique soit pas de
confidentialité ou bien le serveur qui
me demandent sans cesse toutes les
heures selon lui les reprendre quelque
chose et donc c'est là où j'ai eu le
déclic de l'idée de ce café comores king
et en parallèle sa se développer partout
en france et dans le monde
ici la première heure de kourou king est
facturée 5 euros
les boissons et les gâteaux sont à
volonté une formule souple et abordable
notamment pour ceux qui lancent leur
activité
question budget mais pas seulement c'est
important aussi de se trouver dans un
endroit où on est bien etc et stimulant
pour travailler donc que ce soit aussi
bien l'esthétisme que les gens qu'on
rencontre en fait ouais ça va ensemble
généralement et on se retrouve pas par
hasard je pense moi je cherchais pas
forcément un bureau voilà individuelle
et tout ce qui est fait partie de
service où on peut manger sur place
boire son café même quand on reçoit des
clients notamment c'est intéressant
retour aux docks numérique la journée de
travail s'achève autour d'un verre les
utilisateurs du bâtiment arrose
l'aboutissement d'un projet apéro petit
déj les occasions de se retrouver ne
manque pas son choix et c'est un plus
après le boulot c'est par elle en
décroche quand on vous disait pas leur
la vie perso la vie pro là on est entre
les deux ans décroche aussi convivialité
entraide réseau créativité
le coworking séduit de plus en plus pour
toutes ces vertus supposées
il est aussi portée par l'essor des
nouvelles technologies en france plus de
cent mille personnes travaillent ou ont
travaillé donc ce jour dysport